[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Donald sake and
super pumped to be talking about
meditation sleep consciousness is so
much more we have dr. Tucker puck
dr. Tucker Peck joining us on the show
hello hel
thank you for coming on Tucker really
appreciate it thanks for having me this
is my first time doing this live I'm
really excited for this and it was so
great hanging out with you and Jay just
like a couple a couple weeks ago it was
very fun for those who don't know
Tucker's background he's a meditation
teacher clinical psychologist and
founder of drug-free sleep calm an
online course to overcome insomnia he's
also the founder and board president of
open Dharma foundation which provides
scholarships to meditation retreats and
you can find all the links in the bio
below meditate with Tucker calm drug
free sleep calm as well as open Dharma
Foundation org all rights okay let's
start things off with one of our
favorite question stars ask our guests
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our world I guess Mike well in the
direction the worlds are I would see two
forces I've been the last couple years
for fun studying history and the thing
that keeps coming out from studying
history is how much better it isn't used
to be like way way way better right
there's huge sections of the planet
where there's been no war no plagues for
generations that's never happened before
our ability to get along with each other
is increasing on the large scale not
recently our ability to get along with
each other increasing our ability to be
okay with people who are different than
us that wasn't even a thing a hundred
years ago right there was no moral
obligation somewhat of a different tribe
that ideas about as old as our
great-grandparents on what Ian's things
look like they're getting better and
fast on the other hand our ability to
destroy ourselves by accident and on
purpose also seems to be getting like
much better fast
number two seems to be winning right now
it seems like a pretty short game at
this point
but I don't know I feel optimistic about
how quickly things can change yeah yeah
the the the new concentration of our
ability to cause a catastrophic harm on
civilization but also the widespread
diseases that are no longer prevalent
but the optimism of our ability to make
things better quickly
yeah really rapid increase in quality of
life morality ability to get along and
and so on leaves me some optimism that
we can figure this out I think
especially recent history some things
have happened that nobody ever would
have predicted hours beforehand and I
think that actually leaves me kind of
optimistic we don't know what the future
is and the hundreds of articles on
Facebook predicting the collapse of
civilization due to global warming by
Christmas we don't know now let's do the
journey so you were born in New Jersey
grew up in Florida how did you get your
interest in science meditation
consciousness sleep um I got interested
in meditating because I used to just
drive I would drive as far as it was
possible to drive given the amount of
time I did 10,000 miles in 24 days one
time I've been all 50 US states all but
one arguably two of the Canadian
provinces and um I had driven from Rhode
Island via northern British Columbia to
Portland Oregon and um I was lying in
the grass enjoying the sunlight suddenly
was like why did I just drive 6,000
miles to lie on the grass and enjoy the
sunlight there has to be some way to do
this at home and a couple years earlier
I'd read a tick not handbook where he
says we don't need to go to China to
enjoy the blue sky it was like I got to
figure out how to do it the blue sky
without going to China so I like
sprinted over to Palace bookstore read
meditation all day was really like
hooked ever since then I get in a
psychology Maya
my dad died young
and partly because of that and probably
cuz of coincidence there's a lot of like
tragedy in my family in a short period
of time and it felt like everything fell
apart really quickly and I was in a
really good friend group at the time was
a fraternity actually they were like
taking great care of me and I felt so
like happy and blessed and like my heart
was just open from how good all these
people are being to me whereas my life
was tragedy and problems and I felt so
good despite having a lot of problems
and saw many people around me feel so
bad just by having pretty few problems
and that was when I was studying spanish
literature in college and just like
dropped that quickly and switch to
psychology after all that happened so
there's the driving across the country
to to lay on the grass to desorb the
sunlight and you're like okay what's the
clinseq shortcut how can I do this near
my home and then another one is the
father the father passed when you were
told I was 20 you're 20 yeah okay and
then it was really nice for you to have
a group too so that would help you get
through that at the time that's critical
yeah and you felt was kind of like warm
and yeah yeah big like big heart
radiating yeah yeah you know why are
there people with big problems who seem
happy and small problems who seem
miserable that was the question that got
me interested in psychology mmm good
stuff yeah okay and then actually led
you then to okay do brown psych and then
masters and PhD in clinical psychology
at the University of Arizona but then
during that time we were also in 2005
were introduced to Sharon Salzberg of
Insight Meditation Society yeah and then
also Shula dasa the mind illuminated and
then that approved you dr. John Yates
approved you to tea
yeah okay so teach us about that time
period of doing both yeah Jesus about
the time here it was in sequence right I
met Sharon first she's a pretty famous
person now but but even even back then
she was pretty well-known but we just
kept like crossing paths so I got a
study with her a lot despite her you
know being generally hard to find it
seemed like coincidences were always sit
in the same place she's a really
impressive person I can tell you
Sharon's stories that would take the
entire maybe next episode all just
different stories but if you want to see
what an enlightened person is like
she'll deny it but you so yeah let's do
that tell us of our like how what are
her qualities that like yet that made
fair
um I got an email one time from a guy I
didn't know in Tucson two sons a
segregated city south of a certain
Street it's it's a mostly mostly
Hispanic Spanish as the primary language
and it was somebody living in the
Spanish side of town emailed and said
hey my wife Costa Rican
let's make lunch for Sharon when she
comes into town she's a New York Times
bestselling author and she was like hey
do you want to go
I don't know these people I don't know
that neighborhood but okay we spent
three hours there Sharon doesn't know
Spanish the wife did not know English
the husband and I spoke both the idea
that she was a celebrity who had other
things to do just doesn't cross her mind
after I used to put on these workshops
for her and she would come and we'd sell
hundreds of tickets and she'd talk all
day and at the end there'd be this huge
line of people who'd want to tell her
how much she'd changed well I have some
things like that and I would try to get
rid of everybody you know Sharon's tired
let's get out of here and she said no
stop it I want to meet every single one
of these people one time we're having
dinner and I was like why do you hang
out with me and she's like what do you
mean like don't you know Oprah like
you're more famous than most people that
hang out with me and she was like I did
so many years of loving-kindness
practice I don't think I can feel or act
like a celebrity
yeah whoa and what what do you think
emerges from that loving-kindness
practice that gets people to feel that
degree there's like I think it's
particularly prevalent here in the Bay
Area the like petty narcissism right
somebody's like not very important and
thinks they're the most important person
you'll ever meet the smartest person
you'll ever meet
probably in your in your work you get to
come across that um I like you trying to
keep a straight face because some of
your other guests are watching right now
thinking is it me I think I'm a rock
star it seems like narcissism and
arrogance are such like almost part and
parcel of the tiniest degree of success
and in the spiritual world this is not
better you know in the spirit world this
is at least as bad as it is anywhere
else to see somebody who's at the top
and almost seems like she can't act like
she's at the top is really unusual
the loving-kindness meditation its
function is to create a sense of love to
all beings regardless of their character
their qualities or how you feel about
them it's like a hard practice we you're
basically practicing like being a person
loving another person it's this really
simple activity like that and you find
if you do a lot of it over time weird
things start happening Sharon tells the
story where um she's on the
loving-kindness retreat and she knocked
something off the counter and it breaks
and the thought in her head goes you're
so clumsy but I love you she's like
where where did that come from that's
not what that voice usually sounds like
I've had a lot of these experiences to
where like it's much easier to be around
people I don't like it's much easier to
be in touch with some kind of human
essence that
isn't isn't touched by celebrity or as
celebrity feels bad into it mmm
yeah yeah yeah as though the the
hierarchy and one's roles in in like
influencing people just positively is is
is great and it can be present there but
the ego doesn't get inflated the it's
the selfless spirits still there of
loving all beings it's yeah there's I
want will get to a breakdown two of the
different styles of this in a bit
so that's Sharon and then what about
xiulet us as well Suchi lhasa I met him
in all Overton something like ten years
ago
so he was living out in the desert
outside of Tucson he was completely
unknown and I figured now I'm living in
Tucson you know I'll take a little like
break from my my well-known teacher and
this you know local nudnik will be we
fine for the short term and it was a
couple of years before I realized what
sort of person I had come across so he
he wrote this book called the mind
illuminated that you know a bunch of us
the community were helping and at
different drafts of and it came out
three or four years ago and it was like
an instant Amazon bestseller it's all
over the world as recline pinched it
yesterday on on his podcast the book is
a masterpiece and I just got really
lucky to be hanging out with this guy
when there was like a half dozen other
people hanging out with him
and so then so then he and Sharon were
the major role models for you during
this time period yeah yeah Sharon very
much Sharon first like that that heart
space was so I wanted the mind
illuminate is not a heartful book you
know it's a 500-page very academic
intellectual manual on how to meditate
okay and okay I wanted to go in that
order like at first I was turned off by
how intellectual it was
it felt almost like getting in touch
with emotions and then trying to figure
out what to do with them how to regulate
them and still doing clinical psychology
at the same time as all this happening
yeah I've been doing clinical psychology
almost non-stop since I was 20 after I
took a year and a half off to host live
game shows which would be a long story
yeah would you give that up for oh it
didn't feel like a calling I mean it was
really I was in character I got to be
like a you know kind of local celebrity
cuz I would do all these shows around
Rhode Island but I was entertaining
drunk people and I felt like I had gone
as far down that life courses as I
needed to go mm-hmm
so then okay then what was what were the
like what were the culminations
you know at the time period that like
got you to understand was it mostly like
the mind
I'm illuminated that God should
understand how to measure skill and
success in meditation no I mean mind
illuminators pretty recent that that
came out after I finished grad school no
I was so I ended up going to grad school
to study sleep and meditation okay I had
started studying sleep I randomly I
wanted to study psychology and I heard
you needed a lab and the woman sitting
next to me said she knew about a Sleep
Lab and I was like well that's a thing I
mean I just need some love I don't care
about that but I'll go there and I just
got branded it's like a sleep person and
year after year there was some reason to
study sleep more and maybe start
studying sleep in 2003 seven years in I
was like this is cool okay I'm not
trying to get away from this anymore
so gee I'm sorry I'd like to request
just that um the measuring the skill and
success I went to grad school I wanted
to go to grad school to study meditation
with a PhD in clinical psychology which
is trendy now but in
seven was really impossible so it's
rejected from 27 grad schools over the
course of two years and then the
university Arizona I wrote them a letter
like explaining why they made a mistake
rejecting me and it actually worked and
I got in so I ended up in a sleep
laboratory and I was doing some sleep
and meditation studies but the the
problem I kept seeing was there are
basically three ways to test if you want
to know the effect of meditation on
anything there's basically three ways to
test it you could compare people who
meditate to people who don't and see how
they're different on your on your
variable that's a waste of time they're
just totally different sorts of people
there'd be no reason to suspect that the
difference between meditators and
non-meditators because of the meditation
the second thing is you can run a study
so one meditates the other group doesn't
meditate this is really short-term like
that there was a years ago with a Shama
tip project was like three-month
meditation retreats as part of the study
and I think they had like an eight digit
budget for a three-month study Sasaki
Roshi meditated for like 90 years
so a studies not really feasible you can
spend a lot of money to get a slice of
meditation the other way you can do is
compare people who practice more and a
people who practice less so everybody
has done a thousand hours of meditation
used to be someone who did ten and some
of the people who do ten will make it
2,000 the trouble with that is that
practice isn't a very good indicator of
anything right excuse me I'm gonna be
very cool and spit into this take your
time no worries get a shot of me as I
announced your viewers of my first time
doing anything live and the past I
couldn't be as gross as I want this gets
edited out so practice is not an
irrelevant measure of anything right I
can practice basketball for the rest of
my life and and not be anywhere near
Steph Curry when he was a little kid
right so what would be optimal is if you
could actually measure skill at
meditation how good are people at
meditation and then you have a really
good way to measure whatever you want
so make a chart skills on one axis
whenever a variable you care about some
the other axis and see how it relates to
skill so I had to do my PhD dissertation
on the question of how you would measure
skill in meditation cool yeah yeah at
the University Arizona okay now I kind
of I kind of see how things culminate
now so so it was learning from Sharon
and Tularosa at the same time that
you're doing the Masters in PhD and then
that sparked your okay I'm gonna make a
scientific study in the field of
meditation here with skill level being
and comparing that to other variables
yeah yeah cool
okay and what were the things that you
compared it to what were your findings
so the the study was more of a method
study so he was trying to see is there
anything that relates to skill at
meditation so the way I did it was there
was no in prayer hypotheses I'm gonna
collect any data that anything I can
cheaply and easily measure you know I
was a grad student say you can't do MRIs
very easily anything I am a grad student
budget I that the the Varela word from
mind and life had funded it anything I
can measure numbers can measure it so
respiration brainwaves at different
points on the scalp different subjective
measures muscle tension things like that
measure everything you can in a baseline
period and then in a meditation period
see what's changing between baseline and
meditation then see what's correlated so
if things are changing too if two things
change together we keep them if
something is changing unrelated to
anything else we we drop in that left I
think maybe six factors there were three
different subjective measures like how
much you practiced in your life scores
out of mindfulness inventory that these
correlated with different brain wave
increases so the most robust data that's
come out since then is the rate at which
alpha and theta waves increase across
your scalp seems to be indicative of
skill at meditation what's interesting
about that is this only seems to be true
for the first couple minutes in practice
so 2025 minutes in you'd actually want
to be seeing different brain States
depending on what you're trying to do so
somebody's trying to be deeply
concentrated and somebody doing Metro's
trying to be deeply loving you wouldn't
expect them to develop any sort of
similar brain state but in the beginning
of meditation pretty much everybody has
to do the same thing right if you try to
meditate you sit down and the first five
or ten minutes
like dinner sex work things you said in
the past that you wish you didn't
there's like the nonsense of daily life
that you need to disconnect from and you
need to turn your attention inward so
it's thinking about the email you're
supposed to send you turn it in that
process seems to be the same across most
schools
patience Oh in the early phase you you
can probably measure skill by how
quickly people are able to develop alpha
theta that's still pretty speculative ok
so then on one side we have the
developed the like you said is this
parts so critical it's like letting go
of all the distractions tuning attention
inward and then on the other side is
like then there's that same but then
there's the differences that break for
meta versus breath work versus guided
body scans etc okay and then what do
those look like that there's not a lot
of data on particular types of
meditation there's one old study I will
confess I don't remember the citation
but I remember reading the study so
we'll assume it's true where they're
ringing a bell and the Bell should
produce a habituation response right so
the first time you hear a sound it's
novel and there's a an ERP and the brain
a spike in in brain electrical activity
and the second time you hear the bell
it's smaller and the third time you hear
the bell it's even smaller because it's
not useful information to the brain
anymore right if it's not novel so the
one site it's looking at controls
concentration meditation and the pasta
like in an open awareness type of
meditation and so in controls they're
finding exactly what you'd expect each
time they hear the sound there's less of
a neural response in the previous time
they heard it in the positive meditators
they're trying to keep this open like
beginner's mind where you're trying to
look deeply into the sensation of what's
really occurring Joachim and you're so
shin yeah so when people doing that
there wasn't a habituation response it's
the same neural activity every time
right because they're trying to be
interested in in the stimulus in the
concentrated meditation there was no
brain reaction to the Bell they had
trained themselves to ignore outside
stimuli and it wasn't permeating
okay and um so so okay when you when you
find you're finding that skill level is
like how quickly you can see like
through a measure like EEG how quickly
people get to alpha and theta states
it's a very early sort of skill I think
actual measures of skill of meditation
using machine are our thing for the
future at best but okay this was like a
first stab was was a finest correlation
matrix and then rerun the study so
initially there's no hypotheses find
anything that goes together then do the
whole thing over where you're only
looking to see if it confirms and it
mostly did okay okay and then how do you
use meditation with patients in the
clinical psychology practice it depends
so it varies a lot by what people need
right so if somebody's in an abusive
relationship probably a meditation was
not the place to start right somebody
who needs safety somebody who needs
housing you'll also see a lot of places
where people are causing the damage to
themselves and stopping soon might be
possible and in that kind of case I
would I would focus on behaviors you
know making changes where meditation
helps in the clinic there's a huge
number of ways one of the most common
skills of meditation is focusing your
attention right so if you if you meet
somebody with ADHD it's not that they
can't pay attention if you've ever seen
little kids with ADHD they can play the
same video game for five hours they pay
phenomenal attention they have no
ability to decide where the attention
goes right it's gone to the video game
and it's gonna stay there as long as it
wants so in meditation you're precisely
practicing that skill all of us the
first time you try to focus on your
breath find you can't write you get a
half of a breath and then for five
minutes you're thinking about something
else and then you suddenly realize you
weren't doing what you meant to be so
four people are coming to the clinic for
attentional issues meditation is
literally directly
training that for depression is actually
pretty good data on meditation being
helpful for depression as long as it's
not too severe a general principle with
meditation is it is placing you face to
face with your own mind and no
distractions and if your mind is dark
enough if your mind is psychotic enough
you really don't want to do that I was
talking with somebody this morning it
had a psychotic episode and wants to get
back to meditation said six months you
know six months of no psychotic symptoms
and and we can talk meditation don't
touch this stuff until then be in
contact with with the outside world so
in terms of clinical disorders that they
have seen it helped most quickly with is
panic actually so a panic attack is
usually caused by this feedback loop
where there'll be some unpleasant I'm
not supposed to hear like your apologies
everybody out there hope you weren't
wearing headphones you know there'll be
some sensation some unpleasant physical
sensation often in your chest this will
be followed by the thought this is
either insanity or death right this
sensation is really bad that thought
makes the sensation an awful lot worse
which confirms the thought in a terrible
sort of feedback loop if it were
possible to just notice you're short of
breath right now
but you can breathe you've had panic
attacks before they haven't killed you
they won't now then actually the tension
new chest is fine you might be sweating
pretty badly I'm from Arizona you know
where we used to it done sweating no
problem if you actually notice the
physical symptoms of a panic attack
they're inconvenient but they're not
that bad
so I've seen a lot of people in 3 weeks
of meditation have panic attacks quite
under control
the other way to help is the the most
common reason people come into a clinic
is for what's called adjustment disorder
which basically means not a mental
health problem a normal issue dealing
with life and the way that meditation
allows you to have no distractions just
look at your own mind and see how its
operating noticing patterns and gaining
the ability to work with them and
interrupt them by knowing what they are
this seems to help a lot of the people
that I work with yeah yeah the the it
seems as though the the the applications
of meditation to psychological issues
are only starting to be explored at
their fullest it's like the practice
being thousands of years old but its
application especially with being able
to scientifically measure its successes
seem to be more and more coming up with
you know you depression ADHD panic
attacks it's like there's lots of
potential ways of of leveraging
meditation to help with yeah
psychological issues how about the
relationship between our disconnection
from nature and the mental disorders
that we have what do you think about
that um really hard to say I think no
one knows anything about where
consciousness and psychological
functioning come from one thing that
seems to be deeply the answer is there's
not one cause there's a lot of causes
and they're all interacting I had seen a
few studies that schizophrenia is
equally present across prevalent across
all cultures so even cultures that are
living in you know living more in nature
not living in cities the schizophrenia
is equally prevalent I don't think it's
the case that if everybody went hiking
middle illness would go away on the flip
side it sure does seem to help a lot of
people
to get out into the wilderness mm-hmm
okay and then what about the
relationship between like
overprescribing pharmaceuticals versus
prescribing something like a meditation
or a nature bathing that type of stuff
do thoughts about that oh that kind of
sums up what well yeah that's you'd say
that that's a pretty strongly you agree
with that statement like we're over
prescribing pharmaceuticals um yeah I
think if you look at any guidelines
they're not saying start with
pharmaceuticals the incentive structure
of modern health care leads to everybody
starting with pharmaceuticals yes Santos
say that again you have any sense of
structure of the healthcare industries
to start with pharmaceuticals it's
perverse as [ __ ] um so I'm a
psychologist I would make a boatload
more money if I were a psychiatrist
because of the payback that you would
get from the pharmaceutical companies
that would give you kickback on they're
not allowed to do that anymore they've
conveniently made that illegal but no
even just from surance companies private
pay also I'm seeing one patient in an
hour slot a psychiatrist is seeing four
also I'm yeah I'm telling people like I
don't know if you've been in therapy
like it's awful they're hippies really
hard work it's looking at your
relationships it's looking into your own
mind it's seeing changes you need to
make that you are too defensive to want
to look under therapy's awful and the
the idea of that to defensive to look
and making those necessary changes yeah
the idea that you could just take a pill
and not have to look inside it's a
disease the only reason that you feel
the way you feel is because there's
chemicals in your brain that are broken
and we should fix chemicals and change
nothing about your life nothing about
your mind nothing about your
relationships your terrible job is is
fine your bad relationship is great like
pihl's please that's really appealing
and from the healthcare perspective it's
really lucrative so I think that's why
people are locked in this also from the
from the healthcare perspective ah
about when I saw a psychologist and I
talked to his boss the psychiatrist and
I remember I saw the psychologist for a
few sessions and the last session I went
I smoked marijuana and I remember
talking to the psychologist and
explaining to him you know something and
I feel like I'm okay you know Ned
naturally I smoked the pot and he and
he's looking at me throughout the whole
session with you know like I'm wasting
his time and then I talked to his boss
the psychiatrist and it was my time to
get prescribed a drug and I just
remember telling the doctor you know I
think I can work this out I don't think
I need a pharmaceutical I think if I
just apply it apply what I need to do I
can fix myself and now I'm a mere
miracle of modern scientists are listed
all of the things that we're not reap a
Turing our behavior with our
relationships or our family or our work
or just our nutrition or exercise or our
connection nature all these different
things and we just instead of reap a
turning those were just like the easiest
thing possible is this you know this
pill instead but to be able to say
something like nah I'm good I can
repattern those behaviors is like that
requires a really high level of
conscientiousness a lot of work granted
it took years it wasn't an overnight
process but I'm a lot more happier these
days also but it's also as the story
started I smoked a little weed instead
of going to the session in my right mind
quote-unquote and then I've just been a
self medicate er
since then so in summary don't do drugs
kids
I wasn't endorsing I have a
thirteen-year-old these an 11-year old
nephew you know I agree
dr. Tucker yeah I think the other
incentive issue come up against is
there's not enough health care providers
maybe in a place like San Francisco
maybe but most places in the country and
world there's not enough health care
providers and somebody who is you name a
feeling they hand you a pill next client
they can just see a lot more patients
than I would be able to the last day I
felt the need to say on that topic is
there are people who have Repat earned
everything and you know have severe
symptoms and I would not ever say
psychotropic drugs are bad they're
they're godsend for many people who
couldn't be okay without them sure sure
yeah and then the perverse incentives in
health care totally need to be fixed
yeah yeah how about our relationship
between sleep and meditation yeah that
one's interesting actually so if you
google sleep and meditation maybe one
day you'll get to drug-free sleep calm
but in the meantime you generally get
like thousands of pages of if only you
get better at meditation you will sleep
and there's a large sense in which
that's false
so I was talking earlier about the first
ten minutes of meditation maybe 15 20
whatever short periods of meditation are
relaxing turning the attention inwards I
think everybody would be better served
by doing 15 minutes of meditation a day
longer amounts of meditation really can
vary a lot right we're talking about
this earlier if your minds really dark
and you do an hour and a half of
meditation that's an hour and a half of
staring at the darkness in your mind
that's why I don't matter
[Laughter]
want to talk to those demons right a
killer inside me
Yeah right so we do want to do that
though and it does it it's most
certainly not only does not always helps
not always liked to do long periods of
it no not always helps too even for a
couple minutes to reflect on the inner
struggles that we may be having look
yeah oh the mirror yeah I think a couple
minutes always helps but there's it
seems like even in people who've had
really easy seeming lives you know I've
never been abused I've never been in war
zones I've always had enough food
there's decades of crying that you find
when you look deeply into the mind for
everybody and there's heavy stuff in
there you know in the in the
instructions for Jewish mystical
meditation before you start meditating
especially 40 years old be married and
have a teacher the idea is like this is
dangerous stuff don't just dive in this
is not true for meditation this really
is true of long meditation so picking up
a daily meditation practice obviously I
think is a great thing to do I do it I
go all over the place teaching it but it
needs a black box warning on it like
you're taking the I don't remember the
matrix colors that the blue pill or the
red pill
the red pill takes you deeper into okay
great yeah knowledge it needs a black
box warning that you're taking the red
pill as anybody who's taking the red
pill has experience this may not help
you sleep at all right really promote
insomnia yeah
so what you find neurologically is the
more people meditate the better they
report sleeping so on any like
subjective measure of sleep quality the
more they meditate the more they're
pleased with their sleep on any
objective measure of sleep quality the
worse your sleep guns and the objective
is I'm gonna go ahead and say wrong
the objective is brainwave nobody ever
comes into the sleep clinic complaining
they have too much alpha and and too
little Delta what matters about sleep is
the subjective experience but what we're
finding is
sleep skinny meditation makes your brain
more aroused 24 hours a day in a way
that's good in a way that doesn't seem
to have like a negative side effects
like sleep deprivation would I lived for
a summer with a scientist named
Willoughby Britain and she published a
paper that's called awakening is not a
metaphor the neuroscience of meditation
and sleep so it's cool like if what
you'd like to be is to be awake that's
what the word Buddha means it means
wakeful somebody who is awake and
meditation will do that to you but yeah
so my usual tips would be if you're
trying to meditate for insomnia 10 15 20
minutes guided meditations can be
helpful you like progressive muscle
relaxation something that will chill you
out even um rather than cause you to go
deep and what I do for myself what I
recommend all my patients is some other
activity between meditation and sleep
mmm right because both of them are
generally closing your eyes not moving
doing nothing but you're going in
opposite directions meditation is do
that and wake up sleep us do that and
fall asleep so if I meditated mind I'd
do a you know 15 minutes of reading a
book or something so I can transition
between the two activities and then then
where did the moment come for you to be
like drug-free sleep calm like I know I
want to help people tackle insomnia
where was that
yeah so um I my grad school mentor the
the guy that unruhe he died a few years
ago unfortunately the guy that Unruh
jetted me from University of Arizona he
was the founder of this field of
behavioral sleep medicine and if you ask
the National Institutes of Health what
should I do for insomnia they will tell
you a treatment called cognitive
behavioral therapy for insomnia it's
extremely effective I don't know the
like research data but in the three
years I ran a clinic in Tucson doing
insomnia treatment I had one patient
fail this treatment hmm in the entire
time
everybody's sleep got better I was one
of two people in Tucson which if
somebody says they're going to the city
and they mean Tucson that's about a
million people who are using too so
known as the city and I think there were
two
sleep specialist therapists me and one
other guy were the only ones I knew of
so there's this treatment it works
incredibly well for insomnia and there's
not even scratching the surface of the
capacity of therapists to deliver the
treatment it's why everybody ends up on
drugs by the time people got to my
clinic I think this is a part of why the
treatment works so well the people of my
clinic were really motivated they'd gone
to see their doctor the doctor had given
them drugs the drugs hadn't worked
they'd gone to see a sleep specialist
who'd given them different drugs and
given them tests and they still weren't
sleeping and by the time they got to me
you know if I told him to sleep naked
hanging upside down like a bat they
probably would have done it out of the
desperation what the National Institutes
of Health says is you should see me
first and them second so the idea of
drug-free sleep gum was putting
components of that treatment accessible
online to as many people as needed at
once in this this um this includes
things like even something like a
behavior change yeah so um its contract
for sleep because unsurprisingly there's
there's no drugs involved there's a few
things you can change about your
lifestyle that improves sleep so there's
different ways you can change your sleep
patterns around that are maybe the most
powerful component of the treatment a
lot of people are familiar with sleep
hygiene like the way that you'd want
your bedroom to be dark to be quiet not
watching TV in beds become a pretty
well-known concept
I also heard the coils in our bed aren't
beneficial have you ever heard about
that the coils rat you know there's
other those metal coils the spring
mattress yeah I've heard that those are
it's something with heat retention right
I'm not sure yeah there's certain
mattresses are better than others in
terms of sleep hygiene wear meditation
mindfulness really does help is when
thoughts are coming up in the night
about I'm never gonna fall asleep my
life is over this will happen for
ever I will die of insomnia related
causes some mindfulness practice will
help you during the night not have to
respond to those who treat them like
thoughts rather than treat them like
truths that will will keep you up all
night I think the most important part of
sleep is weight waking up only like
naturally I think when you set your
alarm for you know 4:30 so you can get
to work at 7:00 I think that's
problematic
I like to sleep till I am no longer
tired because how long make you get to
work at 7:00 I'm just saying I just
think it's very important to just to
sleep until you're done our shows
usually start around like noon or 2 or
whatever yeah I figured nobody in
Silicon Valley anywhere by 7:00
what do you that's actually an excellent
point some people say you must you know
who sleep with the Sun when the Sun Goes
Down try to go to bed try to wake up
with the Sun some people say that as
well my sleep I think is important is
consistency so if you wake up for work
at 4:30 that's actually for many people
that's gonna be fine
um the older you are the harder it is to
adjust your rhythm although I've never
been able to wake up you can get it just
to do anything right if you you can fly
to the other side of the world you sleep
badly for a couple nights and then your
sleep is fine again
so consistency is important in terms of
the Sun it's not good to see the
sunlight before you've gone to bed so I
worked night shift for many years I had
these crazy like giant what one patient
told me they look like I was in a porno
movie
he's like giant blue blocking sunglasses
it's not good to see the Sun Rise before
you've gone to sleep but otherwise you
can pretty much manipulate with with
indoor light and seeing the sunlight
well while you're while you're awake one
of the things that happens with
consistent sleep is sleep as multiple
brain states and the states have to
occur in the right order in
the right percentage and you're not
getting healthy sleep you're not getting
the benefits of sleep if this doesn't
happen and what most sleeping pills do
is they knock you out you're unconscious
so from your perspective it feels like
sleep but from a neurological
perspective it's not sleep or is it's a
mmm a diet coke version of sleep and so
there are studies that was finding like
if you take ambien you're sleeping more
but you're not any less likely to crash
your car you're not any less likely to
trip and hurt yourself because the the
sleep you're getting with the medication
is not fully restorative sleep so this
also this also brings up the question
for me that there's like something
really profound about certain certain
parts of our sleep where we feel mckible
Eve it's REM when when we especially
when we're maybe at the stage of like
ron was just describing where you're
sleeping until the point rather than
waking up to an alarm but you're
sleeping until you're no longer tired
that section of sleep after like when
you'd wake up to an alarm where you're
just kind of like waking up like a
little bit and then going back to bed
like sometimes you get the most profound
ideas or you get yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's right so um REM sleep is actually
circadian dependent meaning REM sleep
occurs when your brain thinks it ought
to be the last two hours of your sleep
phase it on when it's morning mmm so
with out a consistent rhythm if your
sleep times are varying wildly REM can
be disrupted for that reason but if you
wake up early in the morning go back to
sleep and then wake up again you're
getting a brief period of REM sleep does
a brief period of dreaming sleep and if
there's sleep and insight is gonna come
from it would probably be that yeah
apparently like Thomas Edison you still
like sleep with like a little rock in
his hand and when he'd fall asleep the
rock would fall wake up and be like all
this [ __ ] I gotta write that down things
like that it's um
stuff for like hacking creativity yeah
REM sleep is when your body becomes
paralyzed
so um it'd be possible to hold the rock
during non-rem sleep but it's the same
as though your spinal cord we're cutting
during REM so all your muscles sleep is
a brief exercise in death yeah and I you
know a same read before we started
taping um we're all gonna be dead
probably for eternity
so we might as well get some practice in
the beat and I like that the the the
sleep hygiene is also a very interesting
one I think where we used to be TV and
then we're like okay stop with the TV in
your bed then it's now it's become the
phones the phones yeah
phones are right under the pillows or
like right on the nightstand table or
whatever and that's like come on like it
makes sense like put it away from the
bedroom like get it out of there and
then that helps a lot also you're not
rolling over not only at night and
stopping with using it but also in the
morning you get to like actually be a
human before you are yeah yeah yeah
tethered into the the vortex of of
social stuff and then other things like
not eating in bed light keeping it dark
these types of things sleep hygiene
stuff I think was really interesting as
well so the online course to overcome
insomnia is a drug-free sleep calm what
is the trademark slogan go drug-free
sleep calm well we've been coming up
with a lot of goings I just like
repeating it drug-free sleep calm
because it's a really good URL oh yeah
when I talk to you like I write it down
I was like you don't need to go for
sleep calm you'll you'll never forget it
you'll never forget it drug-free sleep
calm you'll never forget it
that's tickity gameshow skills like that
he did stuff video stuff of you do in
the game show thing host in the game
show no no it was in mid it was in the
mid 2000s like videotaping everything
wasn't ubiquitous yet okay
that's such a good idea I said yeah I
love just see yeah I was looking for it
I just love seeing myself I just love
seeing myself with a full head of hair
pre-sleep calm he'll never forget it
yeah he also adds that you'll never
forget it which also prompts the
remember I didn't consider that as a
motto but that's a great motto yeah also
also one of the most important functions
of sleep is memory yeah totally
so you might forget it you're an
insomniac it's just slipping out of your
mind but go to drug for sleep back on
your memory will improve write it down
sleep sleep acts as an integration for
all of your past memories of your of
your life with the day that you lived so
like you live today your whole day has
to integrate with the past 52 years of
your life and that's what sleep does is
it integrates yesterday with the 52
years of your life oh that's right I get
it
cuz I'm yeah I can't say yeah I'm a
walking on a daily basis did you ever
hear that you're what a walk-in are you
familiar with that term
walk-in yeah no yeah okay and so if you
don't if you don't walk in like your
grandfather didn't like that no no just
these bodies are just machines and our
conscious is separate from our brain
therefore in sleep as it's a brief
exercise and death we wake with our
conscious to this brain but who and who
we really are schizophrenia is not a
disease it's a computer glitch if
anything and we just have to you know
get get you know into this you put this
body on like a costume in here whoever
we are when we wake up I want to see a
Tucker it's just it's it's fascinating
actually wait who who I am on a daily
basis what I just gotta you know I
actually wouldn't agree with that one
there's a couple reasons
sleep is actually not dichotomous from
wake there's not a moment
at which you are now asleep and used to
be awake when you look at an EEG and
score sleep the way you determine
somebody is now asleep he's a totally
arbitrary formula we're out of some 30
second period there's more theta than
there was alpha and that's it sleep and
wake are continuous states and then
within sleep there's multiple states of
consciousness so in in non REM three
sleep I'd probably agree with you you
are nobody in non-rem three sleep
there's no consciousness your brain is
projecting delta waves which is what it
would project if it were damaged you
know your brain is basically off during
REM sleep your consciousness is actually
pretty normal your surroundings are not
right in a dream you feel like you even
though the world is not like it's
supposed to be and you have a goldfish
memory which is why a dream doesn't have
to have any consistency and you can
still believe it's it's real but it's
it's your consciousness in REM sleep
right in my you're asking the question
yes yeah yeah when you're dreaming it
feels like you're you right yes but what
did made me think is my memory our
memories in dreams we don't necessarily
have them you know when we're dreaming
you know we can't recall a memory all we
have is that right now yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah we're as opposed to this 3d reality
you know we can remember but I just
don't remember and I can't recall
remembering anything in my dreams it's
always about the now oh no no you you
totally can like people in lucid
dreaming studies people who are in lucid
dreams can actually communicate with
people who are awake they develop a code
where like you can move your eyes it's
the only muscle you can control so you
know left left right right right means
I'm in my lucid dream now and you can
develop a code where the dreamers can
speak to people who are awake and and
they have no trouble remembering the
code yeah and you can also remember
taking control of the dream state
and when you get when you leave it and
you can write it down I mean you can
write down memories from the dream state
yeah but it's true that it's not writing
to memory in a normal sort of way that
often your dream just you know it the
first ten seconds you're waking than it
ever had on this why you got to write it
down yeah yeah and that's why you got to
practice this this really like run even
mentioned just like sleeping until
you're not tired gives you those last
couple of legs of like wake up tiny a
little bit and then go back to sleep and
then get deeper into that dream take
control of the dream practice your doing
things like before you go to sleep think
about the stuff that you want before you
go in the shower think about the stuff
before you go on a walk think about the
stuff that you want to have your mind
wander about a little bit
yeah and for the the majority of people
who don't have the ability to decide
when wake up time is some external
structures gonna decide that for them it
means like you said before put your
[ __ ] phone away yeah exactly
cutting enough time that if you have to
be up at 4:00 to go to bed it really
enough to get as much sleep as you need
it seems to be the hard part
so the phone in particular I mean I
don't think anyone would disagree that
the phone is addictive yeah and to sleep
with it by your bed and think you'll
behave you know it's like being an
alcoholic and thinking you can keep a
glass of glass of alcohol by the bed and
it'll all go fine yeah
it requires knowing that your willpower
will fail yeah and needing structure and
accountability to make the changes
without resorting to willpower so how
are your phone all the way off at night
you know how long does it take you to
turn your phone off from on from off my
god hours of the thing so it's a it's a
pretty strong barrier to messing with
the phone and it's right all the way
down put it in other rooms you can't
kind of unconsciously grab for it yeah
to to to help create protected time to
get the right amount of sleep yep yep
and it even helps with flow states and
all other kinds of stuff is like you'll
be surprised at how much longer
you'll keep your momentum a flow if your
phone's power to off you'd be surprised
you can stay in Fillmore
yeah okay let's talk about open dharma
foundation founder and board president
there please provide scholarships to
meditation retreats yeah and you
actually have some sold-out ones that
you're teaching ones in denmark you're
sold out in june later this month then
you have ones coming up in San Francisco
and Washington Arizona Australia Germany
oh my gosh you're teaching all over the
place so yeah so okay walk us through
oppa Dharma foundation yeah so the open
dollar foundation I was really sick in
2010 it looked like I was dying I was in
the hospital and I decided that what I
wanted to be done in my memory was a
charity that would allow people to go on
meditation retreats who couldn't afford
to go I was saying earlier you know if
you just want to fall asleep short
meditation long meditations going deep
into your mind it's pretty cool to go
deep into your mind and I just don't
think there's a way to do it
comparable long meditation retreats
where for days on end you don't speak
you don't read or write you do nothing
but meditate and take care of your body
and so I teach these retreats as cheaply
as humanly possible the one in Denmark
it's ten days lodging food and trip from
the airport for a USD 6:30 so I'm
keeping these things really cheap really
cheap but that doesn't include your
flight and it does include any money to
me I get paid by by a donation so all
told to go to the cheapest ten-day
retreat I can figure out how to put on
is a four digit amount of money and
you've got to be pretty privileged to
have the amount of time off from work
and that amount of money so as cheaply
as you do this it is blocked off to most
people
so the idea when I was when I thought I
was dying was I wanted a foundation that
would allow people to go on retreats and
then I didn't die and kind of dropped
the idea for a couple years before a
sudden recollection of life I don't need
to wait until I die why don't we just do
this now so I got some friends and
colleagues and we set up the open Dharma
foundation it's that open Dharma
foundation.org if you'd like to go on a
meditation retreat and you can't afford
to go go there you can apply it for a
scholar
ship if you have some extra money and
think this is a cool idea head there and
and and you can you know make a donation
yeah that's huge you know it's it's
really important to drop the barrier of
entry and make it as frictionless as
possible for people to be able to
explore different things that interest
them and that it's yeah yeah yeah
sorry I have a cold and I just have to
keep popping my ears there we go
well edit this out after the live feed
all of us just start going like yeah
actually we funded a homeless person
recently who applied for a scholarship
and we will fund everything based on
needs so we will buy your flight to get
where you need to go if you need to stay
somewhere the night before we will cover
the hotel we cover the registration fees
Lupe the teacher if you if you really
can't contribute anything we'll we'll
pick up the entire tab and and obviously
if you can contribute anything we would
pick up the remainder yeah you know and
that's also that's both for both
applying for those that want to apply as
well as to give for those that can give
for something yes yes excellent and then
so what let's walk through um just give
us a quick bit on for those that don't
know like what would it be like
attending Tucker Peck course like what
would be my first day with you yes so um
the the structure of the course is a
pretty standard tera vaada Buddhist
meditation retreat and in many respects
so it's noble silence so you'll talk to
me what we'll talk about practice I'll
give it a 90-minute lecture every
evening based on prompts from the
students so there's a little bit of
speaking there and if you're allergic to
peanuts and you want to know if there's
peanuts lunch obviously talk but the
idea is you don't say anything that's
not immediately necessary and this leads
to almost total silence the day is
pretty much just devoted to meditation
so it alternate sitting and walking
mostly for for comfort be hard to sit
all day and walking meditation is
immoral
in games sort of practice right it's
easier to break home with you there's
three meals a day
other retreats don't have dinner but I
like dinner yes three meals a day the
the way that I like to do these I teach
a lot with a guy named Upali
and when we first started teaching
decided some things we wanted to keep
once their treats got big like they have
and want us to do them as cheaply as
possible so they're not gonna be at a
resort on Maui and this makes it
accessible to as many people as possible
the other is we wanted people to get as
much personal attention as they possibly
needed so we don't generally break a
22:1 the student to teacher ratio so
people have scheduled interviews with me
on short retreats every day on long
retreats every second day but there's
office hours when people can meet with
us multiple times per day so I like to
think that on Richards oath you are as
supported as you'd be on any retreat
anywhere it can get pretty hard
traditionally day three and four of the
retreat is the kind of Hell realm day
the first two days are often a kind of
getting used to it it's weird it's kind
of inconvenient once you start getting
into the swing of it it's sort of like
very intense therapy like all the
emotions that you have been avoiding all
in ways you are contributing to your
suffering that you don't want to see
starts like bursting forth in a way that
is intense and and phenomenal you know
to suddenly not have to do that anymore
often by about five days in your mind is
getting really pliant malleable the way
that you decide to focus on the breath
and you can't write it goes there for a
few seconds and it's elsewhere after
you've been silent for a while many
people will find their mind as compliant
you can do all sorts of practices and
techniques that would be totally
inaccessible outside of that that
kind of state I think the reason these
retreats are all selling out is is
partly that there's not a lot of people
teaching retreats like this they're very
hard work and meditation often makes you
want to like chill out not take on this
kind of responsibility be on the road
all the time but the sorts of
transformations that I'm seeing from my
students are so extraordinary and beyond
anything else in my capacity to do for
people that about a year ago I decided I
was just gonna put up with being on the
road a lot rather than having a you know
full time normal job at home it was just
too important you do this while you do
your books this is clinical psychology
practice which is crazy right so
everybody please go to drug-free sleep
calm I really maybe one day I'll make a
million bucks off that and come on the
clinical practice and and and on the I
want to say on on the this deep surgical
operation that these noble silent
all-day meditation retreats really do to
someone it's just it's something that I
find very humbling that I've had the
chance to sit the passion of four times
cool and that it's just that something
that's thousands of years old when we're
only like 25 or 50 years old it's just
like sometimes we have to just like just
be humble and realized that there's a
reason why something's been around for
thousands of years it probably has great
capacity to help us we like you said be
be fully in control of our minds very
beautiful when one's able to do things
like have a when their minds trying to
run all over the place when they're
first sitting and then by a couple days
in you're sitting and you're being able
to bring your focus your focus in right
away it's great you've done the food
with Goa cos that radio yeah so what one
thing he says is he says a lot it's like
commit for ten days to do it I'm telling
you really test this out for the ten
days yeah I think the constantly trying
to figure out if you're doing this right
is
working is this a good fit is a huge
obstacle practice the idea of like as
long as I'm not asked to do anything
unethical I will follow these directions
for a specific period of time to see if
it works for me is a great suggestion
yeah yeah okay let's ask you a couple
questions on the way out of the show
that we like asking our guests Tucker
all right all right all right our first
one more pop here we're trying to do
some subtle pops but we'll also have a
fans a wrong - all right let's do the
first question is what do you think
happens before birth where do we come
from before birth and where do we go
after death
I tend to think of consciousness as
being necessarily continuous that like
birth is a pretty irrelevant moment in
development right birth is moving a
shorter distance than my chair - your
chair is all it happens at birth so that
couldn't be the start of consciousness
it's almost insignificant I think no
start of consciousness can be discerned
I guess my pet theory is you could think
of the brain as like an antenna for
consciousness and so the idea that you
live in you is like the DJ living in the
radio your brain is picking up
consciousness are you not just a brain
of course a brain in a jar picks up no
consciousness I would suspect your brain
and body all of you is picking up
consciousness that as you develop in the
womb and as you develop throughout
childhood and for many of us as you
develop throughout adulthood your
ability to pick up consciousness your
antenna is getting better the signal is
coming through clearer but I don't think
anything really changes at birth such
that we would need to address the
question of where you were before that
change occurred
and you don't think we come from
somewhere outside of this 3d reality
into the earth suits
that question gets kind of recursive and
that like this 3d reality is a product
of consciousness if there were anything
other than a product of consciousness
there would not be a way to know that
that thing existed so maybe it's just
because I'm a Buddhist but I tend to
take the Buddhist view that like
consciousness and materiality co-create
one another where neither could exist
independently and then what about do you
think we're alone in the cosmos no way
does anybody think we're alone in the
cosmos yes some people do yeah no how
could there be that much space and we
could be that unique one of the things
everybody seems to see in mystical
experience is the sense of like oneness
of the universe and that is good right
like you see where people what people
mean by God or holy spirit that like
everything is unified and it's Buddhist
tend to say luminous Christians would
say holy the idea that it's this big
that there's something that luminous at
the core of it and like where the
[ __ ] best it could do no way what
would Satanists call it I love those
guys I don't know I do I just wanted to
see if you did what do they call it
that's a secret okay and then do you
think we're in a simulation
I realized that having come on a talk
show called simulation I should have
been more prepared for that question
but um what do you mean you you take it
where you want to go with it um not
exactly
like that you're a character in somebody
else's dream or something
no so this is all one giant dream in
which we're all equally characters that
would be easy for me to subscribe to
what you see in the mystical experience
is the unification right so like that my
consciousness in your consciousness are
heavily interdependent the only reason I
don't know if you exist the only reason
I could even infer that you exist is my
conscious experience of you even if I've
got scientific implements and I'm
looking microscopically at your body and
I'm seeing cells and atoms and still my
conscious experience of cells and atoms
is the only way I'm getting any
information if if if your consciousness
and my consciousness are the same and
I'm creating an image of your face and
you're creating image of my face it does
seem that there would have to be some
kind of impersonal consciousness
allowing this you know the the the thing
that the radio is picking up is out
there and we could call ourselves
characters in its dream what is the most
controversial belief that you hold
oh I believe in God funny when I teach
Buddhism you know people always ask
about um illegal drugs no problem sex
we'll talk about my own sex life
sexuality no problem the one thing where
I feel sheepish talking about it
publicans is um dropping in G BOM why
why is God controversial to you um
one is is Buddhists are technically
atheistic I think if what you mean by
God is like the guy in the sky who gets
angry when you masturbate nobody I hang
out with believes in in in that sort of
character if you think about God is like
when you use some sort of spiritual
practice or by happenstance all the rest
of sensory experience shuts off and
there's something left that is like
non-dual
and luminous III think God's not quite
so controversial when you say that
that's great but you know here in the
bay people don't say God they say the
universe I'm gonna ask the universe and
they mean God it's the same thing it's
just a trendy or trendy or way of a new
way of saying I think God brings to mind
images of like Oh narrow-minded people
who are racist and hate gays or like a
lot of the people that convert into
Buddhism nowadays come from a like
rationalist background and God is the
ultimate anti rationalist viewpoint but
if you think of God as an experience
rather than in unnecessary hypothesis to
explain data you can't explain that I I
hope it's not quite so controversial
and the last question Tucker what do you
think the most beautiful thing in the
world
I'll just say the first thing that came
to mind do you ever go to Baker beach by
the Golden Gate Bridge
well Baker beat you and there's all
there's the sand and then at the between
the sand and the water there's all these
like small rocks the search going off
the rocks watching it and that sound it
makes when the surf goes over the rocks
mmm that was the first thing that came
to mind we yes most beautiful thing yeah
that's a good one
I like the nuance of that that was great
too yeah
because that specific one is very
relatable for those that live in the
areas yeah yeah yeah
hmm and then the Golden Gate Bridge is
also right there right on the right yeah
yeah yeah there's like a few naked old
people here don't seem that it's a great
if you're a San Francisco tourist you
get to see this beautiful beach and you
get to see the Golden Gate Bridge and
you want to see somebody make it in
public it's just part of the San
Francisco vibe yes yeah that's right
that's right Tucker thank you so much
for coming on the show this has been a
blast
live streaming yeah you did a great job
crystal oh do you want worthies with me
[Laughter]
someone get a clip of that right there
for us yeah later when I get in some
kind of scandal later that's gonna be
the photo of me on all that it's huge
shout out thank you everyone for tuning
in we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode let us know what your
thoughts are also go and talk more with
your friends your family your co-workers
people online on social media about
meditation about sleep about
consciousness drug-free sleep calm never
forget it drug-free sleep calm check out
out links in the Bible oh also meditate
with Tucker comm and the open dharma
foundation go and give if you can or
apply you if you need help with
attending meditation retreats and go and
check out Tucker's meditation retreats
going to go and have more conversations
about this stuff guys we need a more
unified world huge shout out to Ron
for producing and directing Thank You
Ronnie and support the artists
entrepreneurs the organizations around
the world that you believe in support
simulation our links are below help us
continue growing and prospering you find
all those links below and go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world huge shout out thank you
for tuning in and we will see you soon
peace
[Music]